لكن بغض النظر عن هذه الاستثناءات فالحظر
يطال اجهزه الادارات الفيدراليه
الخارجيه والبيت الابيض بالطبع عدد
العاملين فيها ضمن 40 وحده تقنيه واداريه
يبلغ حوالي سته الاف موظف لكن ازمه التيك
توك ليست بالعدد وان تضاعف عشر مرات بل
بما هو اتا خلال الشهر الجاري مع تصويت
مجلس النواب على مشروع قانون يمنح الرئيس
جو بايدن سلطه حظر التيك توك بشكل كامل من
الولايات المتحده هذه الضربه القاسمه هناك
اكثر من 138 مليون مستخدم امريكي نشط
للتطبيق الذي تصير واشنطن على انه خطر ولم
تمنع كل التحذيرات الامريكيين من تنزيله
210 ملايين مره حتى نهايه العام الماضي
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان التيك توك يمتلق
قاعده بيانات
من سكان الولايات المتحده ونصف هؤلاء من
البالغين ومن وجهه نظر او بالاحرى اتهامات
صناع القرار السياسي والامني الامريكيين
فان هذه البيانات ليست فقط في متناول يد
الحكومه الصينيه بل استخدامها في الكونجرس
مايكل ماكول شبهت تيك توك باحدث الاخبار
اخطار الصينيه على الساحه الامريكيه واقصد
في سماء الولايات المتحده من طاب التجسس
المنطاد في الهواتف يؤرق كذلك القاره
العجوز والضربه لتيك توك ستكون مزدوجه لو
قرر الاتحاد الاوروبي السيره على السكه
الامريكيه
125 مليون اوروبي يسجلون دخولهم شهريا الى
التطبيق معركه الخصوصيه هي جزء من كل انها
حرب الكترونيه وشرسه جوانبها تجاريه
وربحيه